really think he can save it turn it
around anymore meanwhile in this game
between Wesley and Prague it is over we
do see a draw and Wesley takes the match
and Lee handshake between the two
a draw means Wesley so when's the match
to take all three points he is really
waking up now in the tour this is his
debut this season Wesley so and now he
is winning today's match to take all
three points has it been a really bad
day for Prague or is it just Wesley we
know he's a monster in this format yeah
it's Wesley I've got to say it's part of
the learning curve for Prague sometimes
he's going to come up against opposition
that just shuts him down he won't always
be able to show off his Artistry his
calculation skills it feels like Wesley
neutralized him and then just took his
one chance today when it came
so yeah part of the learning experience
and it's great to see them chatting
afterwards as well yeah
um maybe asking some key questions about
the opening or about what he could have
done and Wesley for experience Wesley
will be sharing some wisdom yeah